No wonder your breath stinks so bad.
My breath stinks?
Am I not supposed to rinse my mouth out with mouthwash?
But you're using American mouthwash.
That does nothing for you,
by the way. Really?
Yeah. And look,
as you spit, nothing comes out.
Wait, there's something that's supposed to come out?
Yes. Try this.
What is this? This is Japanese mouthwash.
It actually pulls that gunk and dirt out of your mouth. Okay.
Ew. Oh,
my gosh. You see that?
What the heck? All that plaque,
gunk and build up comes right out with that brand.
I've never seen a mouthwash actually pull that.
Whoa. My breath smells so much better.
My teeth feel. Babe,
this stuff is incredible. In Japan,
they actually take their oral care seriously.
Wow. This stuff is something like,
I'm never, I.
My breath literally smells so much better.
Is that why you don't have morning breath?
Yep. Wow.
Okay, is this expensive?
Like 40, $50?
No, it's actually very affordable.
And it's on the TikTok shop.
Okay, I need to get some because this is life changing. Where?
Yeah, I'll leave a link down below in the orange shopping cart
so you can get some, but thank you.